Sao nay ngày 22 năm 2020, nay sau tích miếng nắn, các đơn vị đón quân trên cình cình đạo trường xa,
tục lữ đoàn 1 trong 4 miếng xấu, 1 1 2 quân, đã tổ chức lễ xa quân với lượng và phát đổ phong trào tínu trong 4 năm 2020.
Nói ngày 2020, các đạo trình cình đạo trường xa quân trên và thực hiện có hiệu quả phong trào tínu trong 4 lượng với chủ đề.
Hôm lĩnh giỏi, Antoàn, Lâm chủ, Chính quyết, Hính Đại, Hôm lĩnh thà phu trân cơ bản,
tích thức vấn chấp có trọng của lượng đồng bộ, Chính Sau, Lê thức hành là chính,
hôm lĩnh sắp phương An, Lối tượng tắc chính, chính chừng tổ chức biệt chế và trong vị kỹ thuật.
Hôm lĩnh có khuyền đột cao, Lối tức hành làm chính,
tức hiện hiệu quả đột phá hôn lựa trong tâm là đột phá của lữ đoàn hôn lựa các bạn,
Lâm chủ, Chính Sau trong khai thác, sự dụng trong vị kỹ thuật và thực hiện quyết tác an toàn,
lấy nhiều vụ bảo vệ vấn chắc chủ quyền biển,
đạo của tục quốc và xây dựa đoàn tích mạng, chính quyết, tinh yệ, hình đại làm được tư hôn lựa.
Kết quả, các đạo đã hôn thành tốt nghiệp vụ trong phong chào thi đuối quyết tháng năm đã có mềm bày thực hiện được tạm dưới đơn vị quyết tháng,
hóa phần xây dựa lữ đoàn vấn mạng tận dính mẫu mục tiêu.
Năm ai nghĩ khu chăm 20 xấu, các đạo tiếp tục quán chị sâu sắc nghỉ quyết,
mệ lệ, chỉ thì và hungs sẫn của cấp trên vì cung tắc tham yêu của lựa,
đề mạng phong chào thi đuó của lựa giỏi.
Lột phá hôn lựa cơ bản, Lâm chủ, Chinh Sau trong khai thác,
sự dụng tiếp bị kiết thật và thực hiện quyết thác an toàn.
Bám sắc phương trân cơ bản, tiếp thật vấn chắc có trong lựa đồng bộ, Chinh Sau,
bộ lựa sắc phương an, sắc tình hốn, lấy thức khai là chính,
tăng cường với lựa, dây lựa thị lực, giải giáo dài cho bộ độ.
Tích cửh, chủ động trình bị tốt các mật bảo đam, môi hình học của cho nghiệp vụ với lựa.
Để mạnh phong chào với vị sáng kiến, cải tiến kiết thật phục vụ với lựa và sáng sản chino.
Thử xin trong lò đổi giống vật chất, tinh thình cho cả một chiến see,
tổ chức tốt các hoàn đồng vui trời giải chi trong dựa hình.
Nguyên nghĩ tạo mua trường vấn hóa lệng mạnh để bộ độ ít tâm công tác,
có phần năng cao chất lượng vấn lựa, hoàn thành giềm vụ bảo vệ vấn chắc chục quyền
của đạo chương gia, bùng biển được phân công trong mọi tình hốn.
Các đơn vị vấn đấu hoàn thành một trong phần chăm trường xin, lựa giống và thị dân hổ lựa.
Cô số đặt một trong phần chăm, kết quả kìm chắc là dụ giống đặt yêu cầu một trong phần chăm,
cho nó tâm với phần chăm trường lên đặt cá, rồi đồng thư đàn bảo an toàn từ đối.
Phong chào thi đồ hưởng lựa năm 2018 xong với chú đề, hướng lựa giòn an toàn làm chú, chiến quyết, hiện đại,
sẽ giác từ ngày 20, 2020, 2020, 2020, 2020.
Bộ lễ ra con hướng kết thúc bằng phần lựa giống vỏ thật, lòng giễn thị giục xo cạnh mục,
chiến see các đạo thực hiện, tý môi hình học của lựa tạo không khi suy nổi,
kết tâm hoàn thành xuất giống vụ lựa năm 2018 xong.